first off congratulations thank you I
want to talk about how you're feeling
about closing the Jessica Jones chapter
and starting the new chapter of
mommyhood yeah it's a big one I'm so
excited about it I think it's so perfect
and I just feel so blessed with the
timing of everything playing Jessica has
been such a highlight and such an
amazing thing in my life and it's been
almost five years and this is something
I really wanted to do also so I feel
like the stars all have aligned
perfectly I feel like we lucky something
else he also wanted to do was directing
yeah graduations on your debut so
checking stuff off the live yeah yeah I
got to try keppa so to this season which
was so amazing and so fun and I learned
a lot and did an amazing job - thank you
great office and I'm very proud of it
yeah Blanco's on the season a lot of
strained relationships with Jessica and
especially with Trish obviously because
of what happened with her mom can we
talk about how there might be some
mending because there's some bigger
evils sure I think you know obviously
the end of season two we leave Jessica
and Trish totally separate and that
takes them some time but because they're
all each other has they do find a way
back together is long but it's still
very complicated and it's not the way
that it used to be but they at one point
they do have to put their differences
aside and sort of work together any
anything you can add on to that your
friendships are complicated and
relationships are long and involved and
have ups and downs and we really got a
chance to explore that this season this
season was very much about that
friendship and Trish stepping up yeah
Baker evil then kilgrave I know we can't
get into great detail about what it is
but it's a different type of evil can
you talk in that sense about it
yeah I you know I think the but we were
interested in is exploring a foil who
who is not necessarily powered but he's
you know that that even that that
someone
brilliant it can be complicated somewhat
can't complicate the situation as well
so it was an interesting that was just
the most roundabout changes how jessica
has to apply herself to the situation
because this isn't personal this isn't
kilgrave this isn't someone from her
past this is a really bad person and
Jessica because of her abilities is can
do something and here she is doing
something so she applies herself and she
hasn't really we should have really done
that before so we get to see a different
side of Jessica because we have a
different kind of evil so hard to do but
could you describe the season in like
three words three words three words
three you're the writer it's a what it
means to be a hero that's more than
three words but I mean what it is -
that's seven brace once power and use it
it's really the season is giving and
doing something about it yeah that's
what the season is that's more than
three words about whatever and woman
power God love you for this this is a
show it's meant so much to me as a woman
what does it meant for you guys and can
we keep it opening to maybe how they
come back one day we do sort of complete
Jessica's we leave her in a place that
feels satisfying ambiguous but but true
to who she is and I think for me as an
actress who's played her I felt really
good about where she where we leave her
but of course like you know the
television landscape who knows
everything's open into the in some way
need some female superhero that's
keeping us going ladies give me please
thank you so much
you